ROGER MARTINEZ:
OK, so today, I'm
going to talk about Google
Cloud's managed instance
groups, specifically the
auto healing feature.
So, to show you what
I'm talking about,
let's head over here to the
navigation menu on the left.
Then down to Compute Engine.
And then over to
Instance Groups.
So what I have on this
project is one managed
and since group called WebApp.
There it is.
Let's click the name to
go to the Overview page.
And you'll see that
this instance group is
comprised of eight instances.
So each of these instances
is just an HTTP application.
And it spits out some
basic instance information,
and also has some
built-in functionality
that lets me change
its health state.
Let's go back to
the Overview page.
So as you can see,
each of these instances
is currently reporting
back as healthy.
And the reason for that is that
I have auto healing configured
on this managed instance group.
So let's check out
that configuration.
So when you create a new
managed interest group,
or when you edit
an existing one,
you'll find the auto healing
configuration down here
at the bottom.
And all it really is
is a health check.
So any health check that
you have on the project
will show up right here, or you
can create a new one up here.
It's worth noting that these
health checks are the same ones
that you would use to
configure a load balancer.
So if you want to use a
load balancer in conjunction
with auto healing,
you want to make sure
that the health check that you
use for your load balancer is
more aggressive, and checks
more frequently than the one you
use here for auto healing.
So the reason for that
is that if something
goes wrong with one
of your instances,
you'd want your load balancer
to start directing traffic away
from that instance
before auto healing gets
started with recreating
that instance.
So once you've selected
your health check,
you need to specify an
appropriate initial delay.
So the initial delay tells
the instance group manager
how long before it
should start running
the health check against the
instance after its provision.
This is especially important if
you've got any startup scripts
or configuration
management that needs
to complete before an instance
is ready to do its job.
So I know that this
particular application doesn't
take very long to start up.
So I've set my initial
delay to just 15 seconds.
So if you like to
use the CLI, you
can use gcloud compute
instance-groups managed
list-instances followed by the
name of the managed interest
group and the region.
And they'll return the
instances that are currently
in your managed instance group,
along with the zone, status,
and health state.
So let's keep this
running down here while we
see auto healing in action.
So let's select one of
these instances up here.
1RJ5.
Hit the front end.
And let's make it unhealthy.
And now that it's
unhealthy, the health check
should pick up on it.
So to see what's going
on, let's actually
see the health check that I
have configured for this managed
instance group by going over
here, down to Health Checks.
And there's my health check.
HTTP health check
in use by WebApp.
And as you can see down
here, that instance
is already picked up
as being unhealthy
and it's currently
being recreated.
So let's check out
this configuration.
Let's hit Edit.
So what I have here is
an HTTP health check
that is checking
against Port 80,
and requesting the path health.
But you can select from these
five different protocols.
If you scroll down
here to the bottom,
you'll get the health criteria.
So according to
the configuration,
this health check will
check each of my instances
every 5 seconds.
If it doesn't get a response
it wants within 4 seconds,
it's going to count
that as a failure.
Three consecutive
failures is going
to mark that instance
as being unhealthy.
And it's going to
keep that health state
as unhealthy or unknown until it
has two consecutive successes.
So my managed instance
group is in the process
of recreating 1RJ5.
And soon, it'll be back up and
running in a healthy state.
So in conclusion, using auto
healing in a managed instance
group makes sure that your
instances are running the way
that they're supposed to.
And in any case that
they aren't, they
can quickly and automatically
be reprovisioned and made
available to make sure that your
managed instance group is up
and running at full capacity.
So that was just a quick look at
Google Cloud's manage instance
groups auto healing feature.
[MUSIC PLAYING]